車が2位
俺んちにはですねこの5分小粥部屋
よっとりあえずあった傘の絨毯は引いてるんですけどそれ以外を何もなくて怖いとか
友達とか泊まりに来るときはたいていここで声を使った時点で釣るわけなんですけども
寂しいとても寂しいじゃなんでもないそしてもうすぐ冬
カロリーだけでちょっとこの寂しい部屋に2つを置こうと思いましてコタツを買ってみ
ました
でかいしては amazon の中のと最大10クラスに大きな方ずでしたこれがあれ
ば俺がれ木理様から乗り切れる
[音楽]
というわけで2つを配置するやたらほんとねたぶんみんなあーただのこたつ作り動画
がぁああデータ自体たと床とつ作る度か
あー個作るどうかと思ってるじゃないですか
全然でかいっすよ多分本当みんな総合あるが舌道を受けたになると思うので早速作って
いくよ
さあ
[音楽]
car
これぞ黙れ拿捕とつに関係でこたつ布団的な奴ださあ何
家が止んだよな
って本当にメッツで階ですよねこれじゃぶえっは舌下実家っていうかこんな感じですよ
めっちゃでガーッ面族提案は骨ゲーみたいなことはないとダメですね
ok それでも基本パーたそのターフですね
いいいいいい
4ナンですね昔ことを使った形でですけど捨てるのはずつそのめんどいんですよね
あーなんかこう言うねこういうネジとかを使ってちゃんとで止めないとダメなんですよ
めんどくさいんですけどやるきゃねー
[音楽]
はいというわけでようやく完成でございます本当に何かいいなぁ
懐かし pata といえばこれですよほれあの温度をちゃんとあったかくするとやつ
なんですけどまぁなんせ
なぜもうは冬と言ったらこたつだと思ってるんでむしろなんか昔ことを使ったんです
けどなんで今までこの部屋に来たてなかったんだろうと思ってテロ約2つに入りながら
寝れるというを全ての人類で夢が
叶えられそうです誘っ組み立てるようなはシンプルもサイズですごいやばいよな
でも所得のデッドぐらい大きさありますよね
やっぱり俺じゃあこれじゃあ曲大丈夫横まず大丈夫大丈夫ここに弱いぞとやるな
まあでも全然 ok 乗っても割れません
おとう項目も傷がもたものなんてこれますでこれでもういいからねなエヴァ8まもう俺
ダメだからやばいやばい完成してるは誰か
みかんの5i ながらぶーぶーっ
あっ
単に弾く奴がおっ
me
最後机を立ててえーっ
風
やばいはいという意味でフォトて設置したんですけども見てくださいこの大北
123456人ぐらい入れるんですけどポイントはふかふかのもう人をダメにする
ソファかけるにいつでもお客様を迂回できるラブと聞いみられ例えばせるエイリアン
いろんな要素がこの部屋なんですけどもまぁこのコタツに入っちゃいは誰でも瞬時に
延々の眠りについてしまうその素晴らしい p
ができてしまいました遊ぶ人とか寒くなってきたので皆さん風邪にお気を付け下さい
そして僕はもう2つ叶ってたくありません室内万歳
[音楽]
me
バッハ